this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone
welcome to the 2023 Hep webinar series
the actually the last webinar of this
series uh once again my name is Luis
monserrade your host I'm a second year
PhD student in plant breeding and
genetics in Delirious smart slab Corner
University and I'm accompanied by Tom
Barako and Kim who have helped me put
this webinar together
and lastly I just want to mention that
this webinar series is a component of a
larger project which is the development
of a educational modules that will be
freely available on the Cornell ham
website at the end of this series which
is today but I'm hoping to have
everything up and running by the end of
the month each month each webinar sorry
each module will have the recorder
webinar instructional slide deck in a
set of high impact papers pertaining to
the respective subject this paper will
be provided by the speaker of the module
also at the end of the
um sorry all the webinars will be
recorded and we're available will be
available on the Cornell sips YouTube
channel so if you or anyone you know
missed any of the sessions please feel
free to
um enter the access a YouTube channel
and look at the playlist of the 2023 hem
webinar series
so with that it is my pleasure to
introduce the presenter of today's
session of seminar yamila malfa
Donaldson uh she's an industrial hemp
PhD researcher with experience in
testing processing and cultivation of
industrial hemp who just finished her
PhD at abery squid university did I
pronounce that right
um and her talk today is going to be on
processing expression and testing so
without further Ado please talk to them
Alpha Donaldson take it away
hello everyone thank you so much for
joining us all today as I do my best to
give a presentation about what I've
learned so far around hemp processing
extraction and testing during my PhD
project which I'm almost done with just
in the final few months
um my work has been based at Abra Swift
University uh in the UK and I want to
take the opportunity now to thank Louise
Tony and Kim for inviting me to join
Corner University's hemp webinar Series
this year so be sure to check out the
other presentations
foreign
I will be introducing Industrial Hemp
within a UK context as it gives some
ideas to what um how my research fits
into what's going on here at the moment
then I'll be introducing uh just
outlining hemp processing and some of
the methods involved
um a lot of some of the work I've been
doing is around developing a test
testing method for cannabinoids potency
so I'll be outlining that and then we'll
be discussing some of the extraction
techniques that are widely researched
and published
and then we'll discuss some of some of
the key kind of scientific Concepts that
are important to understand uh in
developing processing methods for hem
including solubility in decarboxylation
and then I will go on to discuss one of
the purification techniques
um that some of my research has involved
micro development around which is
crystallization so we'll be introducing
crystallization and can be solubility
curves that I've been able to produce
and the just a little bit more insight
into the work I've done with Hampton
scaling up a small kind of Step Up and
scale not the method
I welcome any questions at the end
so just to introduce um hemp in the UK
as there may be some similarities also
differences uh to other parts of the
world including the US
so Industrial Hemp here is not our
considered varieties uh cultivars of
Cannabis sativa
which are typically grown uh at Large
Scale as an industrial crop Outdoors
um and
it can be legally grown here in the UK
with a license
the
cultivars that can be
grown are from an EU approved list
of of cultivars that have been bred for
European conditions
and
they are yeah and and they are often
sourced from Europe and
uh used by Growers here in the UK
um at the moment the
hectares of hemp being grown across the
UK is it is increasing as uh demanding
interest for hemp products Also Rises
one of the limitations of current
regulations in the UK
is that the Growers can only limit their
cultivation of hemp to the stalk which
is a source of fiber and other materials
and the seeds which are also used for
several Industries and so the flowers
and the leaves of the hemp plant are
considered waste material and so my
project sought out to better understand
the value in this quote waste stream
um as a means to obtain
some some valuable end products and in
the case of hemp or cannabis
the leaves and the flowers are where
these therapeutic compounds accumulate
mainly collabinoids
hemp is characteristic uh when
considering its chemical composition as
it typically yields higher amounts of
cbda
which is the acid form of the compound
cannabidiol or CBD
and so
the processing of hemp involves methods
and techniques which are looking to
extract and obtain this valuable
compound cbda and convert it into CBD
so I've been very fortunate of my PhD
project was the first at Abbotsford
University
to evolve working with hemp which has
been an incredible
um and privileged opportunity but it
also means that we've had to really
build a lot of the research methods and
workflows from the ground up and so the
picture of the hemp in the field here
was when we first sewed hemp seeds in
and we had um kind of preliminary Trials
of a few varieties of cultivars
and since then we've grown year on year
adding different character bars and and
collecting
um not only cannabinoid data but also
seed and stem diodes
so as I mentioned hemp processing is all
about
um extracting these valuable and
therapeutic compounds
what may what one considered generation
needs to be is the initial chemical
composition of the material that you're
extracting from
um in the case of hemp processing it can
really range and you may be able to have
um very uh kind of cannabinoid or try to
enrich plant material that has been
carefully cultivated
um to to the highest yields or you may
have a lot of um hemp waste and residues
left over from processing hemp for seed
um uh or rather fiber and so your plant
material is not going to just contain uh
cannabinoids it's going to contain other
different comp components as well as
shown in the diagram at the top
and the hemp processing method involves
extracting as much as much as possible
from the plant material of what you want
and then further purifying that extract
to get rid of what you don't want
and then ice and then in depending on
what products you're making in this case
this project was focused on creating
anabinoid isolate you then need to
further isolate that extract to get your
final single compound and like I
mentioned in this case is CBD
and I would I would um argue that
testing is in very very important uh not
only for quality assurance and control
um but but optimizing methods
um for other processing throughout each
processing step and so
um testing hemp testing can involve uh
looking at many different compounds and
my work has been around developing the
chemical profiling method for
collabinoids and flavonoids now our lab
now can use
um for other research projects involving
him
so to develop a collaborative testing
methods
um you need to consider what your what
you want to look at in this case it was
a method developed just for cannabinoids
and so
um liquid chromatography which is a
project which involves separating out
all of the compounds that you're looking
for into distinct Peaks that you can
then use to quantify and find out how
much of each of these compounds are in
your sample
um LCM LC is widely used and suited for
cannabinoids as opposed to gas
chromatography which involves heating
the sample which can lead to degradation
of some of the compounds into other
forms which we'll talk about in a moment
and which can impact your final results
I've also used in tandem with Mass
spectrometry
which has been a means
um to further um distinguish and
identify uh cannabinoids which uh
coalute which means they don't separate
out as well and they
form uh one bigger Peak and so as soon
as on the screen I was able to use these
methods to uh
look to to identify not only the major
cannabinoids of Interest so the cbda CBD
um that I mentioned but also some other
quote-unquote minor collabinoids which
are increasingly showing
um some therapeutic potential
um like CBN or cbdb
as well as kind of Flavin a which is a
unique clavinoid to the Cannabis and so
a lot of testing methods up until now
that have been published have been very
much focused on
um just the the potency so just THC or
just CBD uh in samples which are
typically been developed methods that
have been developed for kind of drug
enforcement whereas um I Endeavor to
put um to put together a method that we
could use in our lab to analyze a wide
range of different components as as
again
um each of them are are being you know
showing more more therapeutic
potentially
um another a lot of work I've done as
well is also a consideration of how many
samples we wanted to get through so
research projects often sample a lot of
plant material that need to be needs to
be analyzed and so we needed a sample
preparation method ready to get to get
the samples ready for analysis in the
lcms
um as quickly as you know in the
shortest time possible in the simplest
way as possible
um so I was able to develop a method
using very small amounts of plant
material
um again when you're developing research
methods you have to consider how much
plant material you can obtain from the
plant without because some for example
we love the work we do with sampling
collaborative content over time so we
wanted to leave the client intact and be
able and not affect too much its grow
but also obtain enough sample for us to
be able to process in triplicates to get
um accurate uh cannabinoid profiling
so the method that I developed involved
the use of methanol as an extraction
solvent so we did some work looking at
different concentrations of methanol
um we did compare with ethanol finding
um my results anyway showed slightly
favorable yields in methanol although
ethanol is another great extraction
assortment to use I also looked at the
number of times the extractions
um were repeated
um often finding obviously the uh
by having data to show that the
cannabinoid content the majority of the
the content um was yielded in the first
extract
um and then once that sold on was
decanted and removed and fresh methanol
added
um there's obviously there's a little
bit more cannabinoids in the second
extraction and little to none in the
third so having looking at different
extractions as well
um as uh looking at solid phase
extraction techniques and to further
clean up the sample to ensure that uh
nothing else in the plant sample would
irreversively binds to the um cat c18
column that was used in the lcms and
then of course a lot of work around the
different uh the gradient being used
um in order to separate out the
compounds as much as possible to get
clear and distinct pieces with this
scenes on the screen and in the shortest
amount of time possible so there's a lot
of considerations and things that need
to be tested didn't want to develop a
method for testing but crucially
important
um for processing as I would argue need
to test as much as possible every stage
in order to
um best optimize an extraction process
so the final method I was able to do to
detect 11 collaboroids and kind of
feminate in 25 minutes
so this is a really neat diagram that I
found in a paper
giving a really nice overview of the
extraction techniques that are used for
hemp
um whilst it's not containing all of
them and these are the ones that are
most widely used in academic research
um for for him
um I will note that here it includes it
makes mention of techniques that are can
be used for extracting fatty acids and
other compounds from the seeds as well
as other plant material uh so that which
contain cannabinoids and and other
chemical constituents
so we'll skip the first one but
um one of the most common extraction
techniques is dynamic maceration which
basically means immersing your plant
material in a solvent uh typically
organic solvent
and then we have a pressurized liquid
extraction
um which uses pressure to improve the
extraction efficiency then
uh then
um
supercritical fluid extraction typically
with CO2 as a quote solvent which uses
changes in temperature and pressure to
to yeah to shift the solubility of CO2
um and and enable it to flow over the
plant material and extract different
compounds
and these these are all all methods with
different uh pros and cons
um not only for yields and
um
and selectivity in terms of what exactly
you want to take from your extracts from
your plant material but also if we're
for costing and and
um other running costs and capital costs
that you may need to consider so there's
no one size fits all for any processor
um there needs to be a consideration of
what's what the potential is and what
you're trying to achieve
some other more newer novel extraction
methods have also been explored such as
ultrasonic assisted extraction
uh which uses ultrasonic
um kind of waves to
help mix up the plant material and break
it break down the cell walls in order to
get a therapeutic compounds and
similarly microwave extracted microwave
assisted extraction and
uh both um or newer novel techniques uh
but are still being
um found in the literature as
um potentially more you know potentially
um different selectivity and
uh for hemp extraction
so
what what we're finding in the
literature is it's really hard to it's
really a challenge to look at different
studies and compare them like for like
um there are sometimes some limitations
um due to the reporting there may not be
a lot of studies don't necessarily
report the starting composition of the
material and thus the recovery
um so they will show a change uh let's
show a yield it will show an amount
that's been able they've been able to
extract from the starter material but
understanding the initial
um sample and the material that was used
is really important not just the
chemical composition but the moisture
content how it was stored in what
conditions and what temperature
um Etc so it can be and it can be really
hard to make that comparison I mean uh
some pieces of Kit are not exactly the
same there are also techniques that are
utilized you must consider a
scale all the way up to Pilot industrial
scale and so the yields and and the
efficiencies will change with that
um
so it it's yes when you're when you're
looking at studies it's really important
to consider
um the reporting and what what
information is actually being shared uh
when considering and and contrasting
different extraction techniques so I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that research at
the moment said that this is the one
best extraction technique to use
um uh is is a bit of a Dark Art and uh
but ultimately requires
um a lot of testing and a scientific
rigor and statistical methods to
um work out what is best for you and
your system
so an important consideration however
When selecting a extraction method uh
particularly around using solvents is
the solubility of cannabinoids
um on the screen are a list of some of
the most common organic solvents that
are used to extract collaborates with
um you'll notice that they there's
listed the the polarity
um however
polarity is should be more understood as
a scale so we have solvents that are
more polar
and less polar
um the the more polar solvents although
cannabinoids are our favor uh
collaborative extraction favors more
non-polar solvents which are more suited
to the to the cannabinoids and their
chemical structure
um quote more polar solvents such as
ethanol methanol
um have
um a kind of a wider polarity in able to
extract a lot a lot more a lot a wider
range of uh compounds from extracts
given given their um oh alcohol group
and it's also important to consider the
boiling point of your solvents as once
you have uh contacted your solvent with
the plant material you then need to use
means typically heat to
um remove that solvent as well and
residual solvent is something that
should be carefully monitored when
producing
um hemp products
I mentioned earlier the use of
supercritical fluid extraction using CO2
so CO2 is a gas however by manipulating
the pressure and temperature you can
take it up to its uh Beyond its
supercritical point in order to change
its solubility
um and this gives you a lot more
selectivity
um as you're able to manipulate these
processing conditions and thus the
solubility to get to Target specific
chemical constituents and compounds
you'll often find in the literature that
um you can also use a call solvent such
as methanol in Subaru critical CO2
extraction to eight to Aid with the
extraction as well another type of
solvent a group that is being
increasingly featured in research is oh
sorry a deep eutetic solvents which are
ionic
um solvents a mixer that could be a mix
from different organic matter and and
they're often encoded as being green
um and non-toxic like some of um the
other aforementioned solvents and and so
it's interesting to see however what
some of the yields are
um for all these different kinds of
solvents in in the case of the deep
detective solvents it there may be some
challenges in removing those solvents as
well so there's still a lot that can and
should be explored into having this
solubility data is really important for
your specific to your attraction system
another really important consideration
for hemp processing that may not be a
feature or consideration for other bio
or you know bioactive compounds and
other plant material is uh the
decarboxylation process very simplified
diagram
um showing the cpga
compound which accumulates during plant
growth which then a enzyme or synthase
can
can um convert into cbda and thda and
then a decarboxylation reaction
which involves the removal of a CO2
group
and the asset group
um in it forms the neutral inversions uh
neutral states of the cannabinoids and
this process is largely driven by light
and Heaton and also occurs over time and
so it's really important to consider if
you are using heat in your process what
uh what's going to happen to the
compounds in your material
um and how you can manipulate uh faster
uh high temperature high and low
temperature to control the
decarboxylation reactions for the
specific cannabinoids
so um there's many many other steps in
the process and sister um kind of method
uh winterization is typically used to
remove fatal lipids and waxes and
involves um again immersing your extract
in the solvent and freezing uh in order
to yeah solidify those constituents and
and then remove them
um and then other solvent removal
methods and and distillation but I
thought I'd skip to some of the work um
that I've been doing around purification
and this is to
attempt to isolate a single component in
this case CBD uh for for a final product
I've been fortunate to have the
opportunity to use a crystal 16 machine
from technobis
um who provides crystallization systems
personalization systems and
um it's incredibly easy and helpful to
use
it involves four different reactors with
um four slots and
each reactor you can set up very easily
using their software a temperature ramp
to change uh the temperature
um and the rate of cooling
um and there's also so I would prepare
samples using
um in in this in this photo of CBD
isolate to start off with for the
medical development and in various
solvents and using a small magnetic
stirring bar at the bottom and to
agitate uh the mixture
um in order to create crystals but how
how are how how does crystallization
work
so
what happens is you create a solution
which is saturated with
um what you want to crack what you want
and so in this case it was CBD
and when you increase the temperature
um the concentration the CBD in the
solution goes up as it solubilizes
within it
and and then as you drop the temperature
the solubility the concentration in the
solution drops as well as the components
of the CBD is no longer soluble in your
solution at lower temperatures and so
this this will enabled
um this this work unable to do some
method development around that
temperature ramp and the concentration
of CBD that you need to start
um to generate these crystals and how
you then and that would then inform
other crystallization steps
so on the right we have a generic CBD um
solubility curve
um again showing this change in CBD
concentration in the solution uh with as
temperature decreases and the CBD
crashes out of the solution
um intentionally with the intention of
leaving behind other components
um and possibly other cannabinoids
so here is one a solubility curve
um that's been generated
by the crystal 16 machine
so I looked at four different
solvents
the green is the pentane
uh the blues the hexane the red is the
heptane and the black I believe is
octane
and this is showing that for the
concentrations that of CBD isolated used
we're getting different solubility
curves and for each of the solvents that
is is matching the the chain of the
hydrocarbon chain of those solvents so
hence having five and octane Having
Eight
um and or right here on the right able
to see a small bar so it just uses this
machine uses hplc files and is able to
crystallize a small amount and
successfully by using these different
solvent systems
what I was able to then do is use this
information
to their use the same machine
to
um crystallize
hemp distiller instead of Simply isolope
so the isolate would have had a uh above
99 Purity 99 content of CBD uh whereas
the distillate had 79
CBD and for each of the solvents I was
able to uh develop systems which were
able to crystallize the CBD out of the
the hemp distiller
um to where to create purity of 90 and
above
um interestingly the octane with the
long hydrocarbon change yielded the
biggest percentage change however
however there's also certain
considerations that are needed for
crystallization methods
um including the boiling point of your
solvents um because it's really
important to be able to remove the
solvent as quickly as possible before
the sick crystals um go above
um go go to a temperature high and also
sort of Belize us back in so
in in my case I was able to
um in my thirds was able to get the
um the head distillate and and solution
in in the solvent solution down to zero
degrees Celsius which correct me from
wrong I believe it's 32 Fahrenheit
um
and then you typically Harvest those
crystals
um at freezing uh wash them with hexane
to get rid of any other impurities
um and then and then and then you'd have
your final crystals
um and with as much solvent removed as
quickly as possible
um so pentaneous typically a solvent
used for crystallization systems
and so now I've been taking this work
a step further just recently I've been
looking at a on a slight scale up using
a jacketed reactor
um you've got it on a
heated stone plate
um so I've got a kinetic star inside and
the temperature probe coming out the top
and then uh the pink is the actually the
glycol from the chiller
um and so I was able to
to uh weigh out
the have distillate
and add a solvent uh in this case was
octane I gave octane ago the other day
and I was able to because I knew the
temperature to start out and then
wrapped down to to freezing I was able
to get a batch of crystals and
um in the process of preparing for
analysis to to determine the Purity
um so yeah this has been quite
interesting and a nice work
so just to summarize
um my we're interested in industrial
hemp now as a source of therapeutic
compounds in addition to its kind of
uses for seed and it's stalk
and but there needs to be more research
and work done to develop and optimize
processing method specifically for hemp
um which uh and it's in its materials
with all its different chemical
constituents
um LC liquid chromatography is is a
widely used method for an adenoid
profiling uh and other and other testing
methods can develop be developed with it
um with it also kind of introduced some
existing and love abstraction techniques
uh they're not being a definitive kind
of best one
um but it depends on your processing
objectives
um
nonpolar solvents are better suited for
kind of cannabinoids
um but some of the safety issues uh mean
that they have fallen out of favor and
and so
um other more polar let's say um
solvents um are being used such as
ethanol
um just discuss the decarboxylization of
um of asset collaborates neutral
cannabinoids which is an important
reaction step in your processing method
and one to consider
um yeah for your selection of extraction
method and I've just um kind of outlined
some of the work I've been doing
um to develop uh crystallization methods
to purify hemp distillate
um to isolate CBD
just a little bit a little bit about me
just before I go
uh yeah so I'm based here in the UK
um I have a background in chemical
engineering business and and have
experience uh uh communicating science
in schools uh I've also recently founded
my company premiopotic and um won
um several Awards including young
innovators award uh I am I've learned so
much and it's really been honor and
privilege to be able to work with
cannabis
um especially in a country where it's
only um medically reasonably medically
legalized
um and I'm always Keen to connect and
learn as much as I can from others so do
check me out on LinkedIn and feel free
to email me anytime thank you so much
for this opportunity and I apologize for
the uh interruptions thank you again
thank you Jamila I was great
presentation
uh and I can see that you have several
questions
okay thank you so much for your
questions I'll start from the top um
Aaron asks where were the samples over
time taken from the plants
uh where were the samples over time
taken from the parks Okay so
um
I presuming that's the parts of the
plant so you're asking about do you
asking if I've get gotten this wrong
um so
far from the field the leaves were
sampled
um at three points along the plant so
kind of
uh bottom mid and top
um we also tried sampling just the
outermost more sorry the most mature
um leaves uh most extended mortalities
towards the top
um and then we've also taken the
flowering tops as well and Sample those
um yeah
I have done a bit of work around some um
analyzing leaves
um sampled that I've taken up along the
plant
um and do find a lot of variability
um although in the literature it does
show that collabular content does
decrease as you go down along the plant
um but the plants are not homogeneous
and and so yeah considering where you do
sample
from on the plants is really important
um but do ask again if I've not got that
quite right
um pressurized liquid extraction is not
would it be considered the same as a
heat press um just giving you're not
using the liquid uh but yeah that's just
more mechanical thermomechanical means
of extracting
um but that I would say is more suited
for cannabinoid Rich light material
um that you wouldn't necessarily find in
a hemp grown here
well it can be but
um we're yeah we're waiting to hopefully
get access to a wider range of uh
cultivars with higher calabinoid
contents and then the ones we have at
the moment
thank you for your question Fred Peter
do any solvents use during extraction
carrier risk or reacting with the
desired extracts
do any solvents used during extraction
carry a risk of reacting with the
desired extracts
um
all right I wouldn't say that there were
any uh particular
reactions the risk being however
um the insufficient removal of that
solvent which would be a problem for
your extract
but thank you thank you for this
informative presentation you're most
welcome I am not an expert in extraction
techniques I don't think anyone is but
Keen to know whether increased nitrogen
fertilizer rates affects cannabinoids if
yes how uh
yeah very interesting question around
nitrogen fertilizer I was not involved
in this work but there was a very small
nitrogen trial done with the hemp growth
here um on campus
um if you want to email me
um I'm sure we can find some more
research um that's already been
published on this topic uh but the
hypothesis is yes that
um you know increase nitrogen
fertilization would increase uh
cannabinoid content uh what I think the
nuances is uh what point of the growth
stage that you add that fertilizer and
how much so that's where the work needs
to be done and maybe you can research
that
uh thank you Michael is hemp CBD safe to
use after that process
um so
it depends
uh depends what part of the process
um so we had extraction purification
isolation and that whichever point you
kind of get a product out of at each of
those steps will determine kind of the
final product
um and so right at the end you're going
to get an isolated CBD and I wonder if
that's what you're referring to
um the safety of CBD isolate has been
very much up for discussion
um
I I would say the literature points to
CBD isolate being safe to consume in the
right amounts
um
however a lot of the literature now is
demonstrating the efficacy of a
like a kind of chemically rich and
comprehensive extract with which um I
guess people refer to as being full
spectrum and so and this is why I
endeavored to make sure that our
analytical work would be able to capture
as many of these cannabloids as possible
which together
um can uh have a potentially greater
efficacy than CBD isolate on its own
um I would argue that uh this this
effect known as the Entourage or The
Ensemble effect requires a lot more
research which is very exciting
um but yeah I would I would say
definitely do research if you have any
questions do Reach Out
um Fred
what temperature have you found to be
best for
decarboxylation of hemp we've been using
240 Fahrenheit whereas the with THC
cannabis we use two to five Fahrenheit
do you agree concur that CBD and CBG use
a hot temperature decarboxylate than th
THC flour thank you okay so
um I fortunately have not done any
personal work around
um decarboxylation
um however
if my memory records there has been a
study uh looking this kind of a a kind
of General
approach to decarboxylation and
um I I think it's really interesting
your results
I think it was the
hot temperature
paired with a faster reaction time
um that was more selected towards THC
but I'll confine the paper and send it
to you I'm free I just don't have it
um at the top of mind my mind at the end
of this day
um but yeah do get in touch
right it's love to know what kind of
work you're doing uh Daniel could you
please tell us a little bit more about
your startup her and positive thanks
um thanks for your interest Daniel
um yep my probiotic I started last year
after winning a kind of dragon uh uh
shark attack that's the newest version
uh Shark Tank kind of style
um competition here at University and I
sits there and received a lot of support
um and I've been developing
um plant-based Foods uh from hemp seeds
and partnering with the Innovation
Center here and so yeah this has been
during the final year of my PhD so
um just had to take a
um you know I've done what I can and
I've gotten started with a few products
um but I'm Keen to do more and yeah
would love to speak to anyone uh about
it more so do get in touch
and they stay connected over LinkedIn
thank you for your patience wow that's
quite a few okay great
are we good for time perfect San Hi Sam
I have heard parenthetically that the
roots of the hemlock contain similar
therapy to compounds so do you see one
will run um do you run see any reports
on the root material the literature has
anyone looking at that or would you
consider it a possibility worth
exploring yeah
um
so the yep the roots of the plants
um yeah plus we can contain
therapeuticutic compounds not you
wouldn't you wouldn't see cannabinoids
accumulating in The Roots however there
may be other compounds um such as
flavonoids and I'm hoping to look at
some data
um that I've taken of some root samples
myself and uh do drop me a message and I
can get you that as soon as I can I'm
I'm writing up my thesis so it should be
in there uh but yeah definitely worth
exploring
Mommy I had it okay
to explore all of the potential value
from the plant
why is a heat press not part of the
extraction pipeline is it not considered
extraction when you create roasting
squeeze the flour under a heat press so
yeah absolutely and this is a one
extraction technique but I would argue
is more suited for a um kind of tri-con
resonance uh kind of Rich
um you know flower
um that you're able to cultivate and
Sample
um as as opposed to him I'm not saying
it's not possible with hemp and it just
there just may be more better scented
um processing methods and for kind of
low cannabinoid content material
okay
faheed my other question is which gender
of hemp plants male or female produce
greater amount of cannabinoids
um so
it depends uh
hemp plants can be
moneracious or diocious so you can have
monothesis you have the males on
individual and females on individual
plants and diures you can have on the
male and female reproductive systems of
both plants
um it is under it is understood that
female flowers can produce higher
amounts of cannabinoids but that is if
they are not pollinated and hemp
fields of hemp typically contain both
male and female flower uh yeah both male
and female plants
um and so unless work has been done to
uh respectively remove the male plants
you are going to get a pollination which
will impact the amount of cannabinoids
but typically when you are cultivating
cannabis for anabinoid Content you want
unpollinated female
flowers
thank you Ethan is waste disposal a
consideration when choosing a solvent
yes absolutely um yeah as it should be
with um
yeah
um
or with any methods you should consider
the kind of top life cycle and the waste
um when this is one of the limitations I
guess or considerations for solvents
um these solvents are you know they need
to be stored adequately in typically
cool dry places
um and and yeah they need to be disposed
of appropriately you can't just put it
down a drain
um and so this these are definitely
considerations especially when you scale
up and have industrial kind of um
solvent extraction methods
um yeah how you're going to obtain and
store and then get rid of these tokens
so yeah definitely in the consideration
thank you and Tyler
has there been any tests looking at the
relationship between CBD content and
physical characteristics such as style
size of
I'm presuming it's the stock thickness
and strength of the Indus in industrial
hemp plant is this relationship
proportional
um this is yeah really interesting
hypothesis so
um if
if you consider
yeah it's a really interesting
hypothesis so would it say that I've got
a study to hand
um which shows this
um typically you have
uh you know it's very important to have
a strong stalk to support the plant
which will in turn support the flower
product and leaf production where the
cannabinoids accumulate
um however however there are
hemp cultivars that are better suited
for fiber production because they can
grow taller
um with you know
you know a thicker stalk maybe
um but then that will impact their
ability to produce cannabinoids
um so that that's the kind of hypothesis
that with a stronger or thicker or
taller stalk
um more of the energy is going into
creating that biomass and not for
cannabinoid production
um but this is definitely something that
um I will look to see in the literature
and I hope you can maybe add too if you
do your research
um do let me know
those are all the questions I have in
the Q a if there are any more please
throw them at me oh
yeah it seems like there are no other
new questions
just check the chat
well
if
no more questions are entered then with
that I would like to thank you
Jamila for
being the speaker of today's session of
today's webinar and all of you for
joining us not just today but throughout
this webinar series uh it has been a
great pleasure to for me to be your host
in this 2023 where we're in a series and
please join us next year foreign
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu